he's coming to save
come
us
[Music]
[Music]
behind me is gabby's vision board i'm
just going to take a quick photo
so that i can take it to my studio
without her realizing
gabz's happiness is paramount to me and
when i saw her put this vision board
together it made me so bleak because
in today's landscape most of the [ __ ]
just isn't possible
but let's take a closer inspection and
see what we can do to make these visions
a reality for gaps
firstly in an island okay i
can't arrange an island but what i can
do is pack the car without gabi knowing
arrange a place for joey to stay drive
up to a seaside town called langaban
blindfold gabby can you see anything
unpack the car walk her down a jetty
get her on a boat
which will take us to this houseboat in
the middle of the bay
take a big step
[Music]
love it baby this is our own island
on the water it's our own island island
bedroom one two three bedroom four five
number six seven room eight this is the
ninth room there's so many rooms
kitchen number one upstairs kitchen
slash dance gear roof
safety thingy another safety boat thingy
lounge number one upstairs lounge
tanning deck
[Music]
when i woke up the next morning i tried
my favorite trick coffee
but then i realized this was indeed
about gabby and not me
[Music]
next on our vision board is a yacht i
don't know how to capture a yacht but
what i do know
is that two paddles a sheet of material
and some cable ties make for a sale and
when added to a blurb mattress you get a
really dysfunctional yacht
it took sale really quickly but the
problem is that we couldn't steer it
so eventually we drifted so far up
beyond the boys which i told gabs were
shark nets
sorry that's a bad joke they they not
shark nets at all
and luckily we got a coast guard's
attention who came out to save us
maybe we should
this is the perfect time to jump off a
waterfall like in this picture
this i recreated easily by jumping off
the top deck
[Music]
i don't know why this was on a vision
board because gabby doesn't like heights
very much or the cold water
next on gabby's vision board are a bunch
of illustrations of couples
laughing in bed and hanging out so i
tied up a blurb mattress to the end of
the boat
put on a tweet asking you to ask us
anything which
started some pretty interesting
conversation when are you
having a little brew
honestly okay i'll i'll say this i want
a child but gabs doesn't
no little bruise not a discussion that
we're having
will be having it now no plans for a
little girl
but maybe yeah it sounds good sounds
positive let's move on we locked it in
you heard a tear first lucy asks
what's a creative project you guys
always wanted to do
i mean i guess like building our our
home together has been oh yeah building
a house yeah
create a project that's right that's
like still sort of ongoing and fun
fishing yeah
if you had to choose a different career
what would it be lawyer
you that's what you do
you got to choose a different one i
would be a musician yeah i know you
would be
or
that's cool marius asks what does gabs
think about the thumbnails where she is
used for a higher click rate i guess
maybe because i'm not like a youtuber
or a youtube watcher that it doesn't
phase me but i don't feel like any of
them are inappropriate
wait until you see this one i'm drinking
graham simmons pineapple on pizza
question mark
of course of course come on i know
actually don't we get [ __ ] pissed off
about the [ __ ]
well banana goes on pizza happily so why
not pineapple
yeah why jay pimp daddy
asks alay or nyc nyc
for sure actually yeah i think also
why it felt easier if you live there
it's just it's
just like you could just walk out your
front door and be anywhere
allez is too much traffic things are so
far away from each other the waves are
[ __ ] so you might as well not even
new york new york's just better all
around better
alan fox when will your show be on
discovery plus
it'll be coming soon yeah
i think that's all i'm allowed to say i
don't know i don't want to get like
fired or something
steph the dink gabs what is the most
ridiculous thing
you've had to put up with i bet dan is a
handful
i'm a word yes definitely but
we made a whole we made a whole film
about we made
yes we we made a video called
10 reasons why not today to filmmaker
and gavis is just
she cut me deep so you can go watch that
video
festivals aren't really a thing right
now but what i can do is play our
favorite song on my boombox speaker on
the top deck
i love it dj
spin that [ __ ] yeah i'm spinning it just
so then
lastly she has this on her vision board
brew
this would make for a great story time
segment actually this part of the vlog
is called story time which is brought to
you by my friends and collaborators at
storyblocks because without unlimited
access to their high quality stocks
i wouldn't be able to give you a visual
representation [ __ ] that was good visual
representation
of my story or in this case gabby's
story and you just have to imagine it
which would be boring
i start yes well firstly brew means
globally like-minded female or male
friends
it's actually a bit more than friendship
a career is someone you don't even know
you need in your life yet
and when you meet them it just makes so
much sense
there's a community of us around the
world that identify with each other
through
our vulnerabilities goals and dreams and
we give each other the validation needed
to know that we're all
[ __ ] awesome you know it's like magic
without the magician
it's real i don't know i just love the
idea of it and i want to help shape the
idea that it's not just a man thing
like bro it's through the frame you
never knew you needed
that was awesome do you come up with
that
scabs will find i've been watching this
video why the random time away
it really was something special i love
you gabs alrighty more about storyblocks
which exists to bring your stories to
life without sacrificing your vision
due to time budget or resources
every creator should have a storyblocks
membership their unlimited all-access
plan gives you unlimited downloads to
everything in their library
you can try out multiple options quickly
and find the perfect fit
so you can create more and spend less
without sacrificing quality
they have an ever growing library of
over 1 million stock assets
including 4k hd footage after effects
and premiere pro templates
music images sound effects and more all
assets are royalty free so you can use
your downloaded content
anywhere for personal use or commercial
so click on the link in the description
and sign up today to elevate your video
creation process
if you support me and my journey go over
and support them too
other than that it's amazing to be back
with the vlog
and i've missed this uh connection
that we share so yeah don't forget
you're awesome through and
i'll see you next week
[Music]
you